what's up gamers it's your boy today
we're playing I honestly don't remember
this is so freaking cool guys I cannot
tell you guys how excited that how
excited I am to play this game creator
oh my god is that me is that me can i
tonight kiss hello there
let's not make it awkward we just got
started feeling I am a blue-eyes White
Dragon
enema for media calls me racism because
I made the black character listen I got
a plan safe these days rock may need a
base you too man nice man goddamn boy
this is not about me customizing Miami
to evil characters this is about sexism
in video super high
oh that freaks me out oh my god that
freaks me out dude I never done that oh
[Laughter]
whoa whoa only slow-motion - whoa Wow
I'm in slow motion games Wow
oh dude I kind of like different stances
that's sold out how you doing baby you
have a fight with a man this ain't some
before I'm God dude even buckets got
nothing on me Wow Wow whoa this is so
cool
ha choose destination on the mat all
right let's go ruins I can't wait to
play this this is so cool
I am NOT playing a video game like this
maybe Gorn if you guys remember that oh
Jesus it looks like it looks like I mean
Dark Souls I'll do this light looks like
a bunch of stuff over here well I do
this is what we're having Sweden this is
what we call the Viking stains come at
me from the floor okay
oh okay signorina let's put it on the
hardest special mode what does that mean
okay
kind of hard a point when your arm is
I'm putting it on the hardest dude can
you wait for my own wait for me I'm just
fine wait for my office god dammit
alright
what you got going ah I got your purse
and Eric
Oh God
[Music]
stop fighting aah are you crazy you're
crazy
you're praying you're crazy don't put
your dining on the Turnpike god I'm
gonna die you take stock the free stop
stop stop stop
everybody stop I can't see anything I
can't see anything honestly where am i
right
that doesn't count right bucket I
summoned me
ah how did that happen whoa oh my god
I'm a friend
[Applause]
[Music]
ah
oh I expect them
ah thanks that's great
Jay says what's wrong with you don't
sneak up on a man with all right back
off I'm getting like you're making me
very angry
it does not want to make sure this man
open told it to lymphocytic dumpling
okay someone that I have the dagger I
have the dagger of distance the dagger
of distance ha ha yeah
[Music]
hey what are you doing
come here come in
oh hey when right right it's this is an
interesting stance oh my god
okay that's easier let's do medium wig -
I want to try the kick this time come da
cunha what honey times a fun da
fantastic anezka Ensco
so go on it so go on it some more
now excuse me excuse me shoot what is
happening
hop
ah
Oh
and skin'
grab the sword
what
mr. Fang number boy ah shoot haha no god
damn it
let me catch it no this game is so fun I
give you like a longsword and you can
hold it like this that's so cool like
you can just hold it however you want
like a goddamn psychopath ah here we go
[Music]
don't don't don't at the NASA you got
something right there in your nose there
you go fix it this is how we do it in
sleep does this arena have any goddamn
weapons see I don't even feel weird
about jumping anymore oh here we go
here's weapons dude I got freakin money
health potions I'm healed guys maybe I
should try the bow and arrow okay works
all right so you just like okay then
okay
all right this shouldn't be too hard hey
yours okay ah done
oh we're doing a different name on fine
hey hey hey back up back up
[Music]
okay headshot time oh you're not so
tough now are you little girl stop stop
stop what I say
what I frickin say why would you die
honestly you're embarrassing yourself
god dammit whoa that was awesome that
was on a frickin night - any last word
son of King star didn't think so so so
look guys look at this it's I pick one
and then I do this wave three voice
let's freakin news
oh boy angry Blainey attack never stop
never stop Twitter corny attack
I got your knees boy
[Music]
release
anyway guys hope you enjoyed this
episode smash night though the Viking
was killed that day they say he lives on
in spirit forever
oh-oh-oh-oh-oh-oh sweetest boy angry
Swedish boy a knee attack never sir
never stop Swedish boy knee attack
I got your knees boy
[Music]
[Applause]
ah sweet release